As for the former
president, he briefly took the stand
today in the witness
stand in the New York
civil fraud trial,
came at the judge's orders
after the defendant said that.
He said this during a break
in testimony
by his former lawyer and fixer,
Michael Cohen.
This judge is a very partizan judge
with a person who's very partizan
sitting alongside
and perhaps
even much more partizan than he is.
As you know,
the former president
is already under a gag order
barring him from attacking the judge
and the judge's staff in particular,
the judge's clerk.
He's already been fined $5,000
for violating that order.
So when the court return,
the judge called him to the stand
where Trump insisted
he was not talking about the clerk
who sits to the judge's right.
Instead, the former president claimed
he was referring to Michael Cohen
in the witness chair,
to the judge, to the judge's left.
Now the judge
replying, quote,
I find that the witness is not credible
and finding him $10,000 in response.
Joining us now,
senior legal and legal analyst,
former criminal defense attorney
Joey Jackson,
and CNN's Kaitlan Collins, host,
The source
coming up at the top of the next hour.
So, Joey,
how unusual is it for a judge
to haul a civil defendant
up to the witness stand?
Listen to what he has to say
and then deem him
not credible and find him?
Yeah, Anderson, it doesn't happen
that often. And obviously it does happen.
It happened here.
But it is certainly a significant step
for a judge to do that.
And so think about what happened here.
Number one,
the judge issued a determination
that there was a violation
of the gag order.
But more importantly, the judge held Mr.
Trump accountable for that violation,
accountable to the tune
of what he understands,
and that is money.
And so I think what the judge
is doing by doing that
and get to the credibility determination
momentarily is saying, look,
what I say matters.
If there's a gag order,
are you going to follow it?
And so I'm going to hold you accountable
now and I'm going to deter
you in the future from even thinking
about violating my order
as to the finding of no credibility
by Mr. Trump.
That's huge to think about the case
we're talking about credibility
is everything in a case like this
where you're running a company
and you're alleged to have engaged
in persistent fraud.
If a judge deems
you not credible for something
as simple as who you're referring to,
think about what
the judge might be believing
with respect
to testimony involving this company
and and the fraud
that they're accused of.
And so a wholly significant development,
by all accounts,
with respect
to the merits of the case
and with regards to him not abiding, Mr.
Trump, that is by the order
that the judge imposed.
Take a look at the body.
And, Caitlin,
any sense
how this is going over
in the Trump orbit?
Well, I mean, I can guarantee you
that when they all woke up
this morning, Trump's
legal team
and Trump himself,
they did not think
he would actually be called
to the stand today.
But this is a result of, you know,
nearly every day when he is gone
into the courtroom here in Manhattan.
He has spoken to reporters
railing against the attorney general
here in New York,
going off on the judge, of course,
what the judge believed,
going off
on one of his law clerks again
today after he had already
posted pictures of her.
That was the reason
he got that first sign.
It was kind of seen as a technicality
because he left the post
up on his campaign website
but deleted it from his truth social.
And I think the 15 grand
is not something that you know,
is obviously going to hurt
someone like a Donald Trump.
But it is the essence of it
that he is now
facing punishment
for the comments that he is making.
And he got up there
and tried to make his own argument,
try to argue
that he wasn't
actually talking
about this law clerk,
even though the judge noted
she's had a lot closer to him
than Michael Cohen did,
who was in the witness stand.
And the judge quickly
did not believe him.
And I think this is the first time
we've seen Donald Trump actually
testifying in an open court
in more than a decade.
And he is expected to actually testify
in this trial
not related to this matter, Anderson.
And it doesn't seem to bode
well for what that testimony
is going to look like.
And given the fact that
he is attending this continues
to attend this trial.
I know there were some days
he wasn't there,
but it's
I mean, it's
just a sign of how important
he thinks this is. It's personal.
It is incredibly personal for him.
That is why he is
I mean, he's flying up here from Florida
to come to this.
It's not like he's
just hanging out in New Jersey
at his nearby club.
I mean, he is
he went back to Florida today
after leaving that courtroom earlier
and he has sat in on it multiple days.
He is not,
you know,
just sitting there quietly
paying attention to the proceedings.
We've I've heard
from our reporters in the room,
you know,
he's at times throwing his hands
up in the air,
kind of rolling his eyes
at the proceedings.
Him and Michael Cohen
being in the same courtroom
in and of itself is something shocking.
I don't think they've been
in the same room together
in about five years.
And Michael Cohen
was in there, obviously,
and we've seen
how their relationship
has completely devolved
into and deteriorated.
And it's just remarkable to see,
you know,
that this is something
he really cares about.
The outcome of this,
even though largely it's
already kind of been decided.
And, Joe,
what happens if he
runs afoul of the gag order?
Again?
Yeah, I think the judge is setting
the tone, Anderson,
as it relates to what he expects
and anticipates.
This is not a broad, hard
to follow gag order. It's a gag order.
And as much as the judge said, listen,
staff is off limits, do not address that.
He did.
And so what
the judge did, I think, is in
keeping with what judges like to do,
and that is ensure decorum, ensure
that orders are followed,
ensure that people are not attacked
or demean for simply doing their job.
And it's really setting the stage
for moving forward
that if you do it again
and again, deterrence,
that I'm going to have
something to say about it.
And so I think we could see
fines that increase
and continue to increase.
And remember briefly
this is not the first time
in connection
with this case that he was fine.
He was fined because of not complying
with handing over
information to the attorney general,
to the tune of over $100,000.
And I just would add that in a case
where a judge is making
a judicial determination
about whether you're responsible
and certainly
your licenses are at stake
in the state of New York
and what you do
and your business practices
and what the findings are.
I think he's the last person
that you might want to get upset
and who you might want to
not follow their orders.
And so we'll see whether Mr.
Trump could comply with that
moving forward.